[Musique]
des dizaines de milliers de morts en
Arménie soviétique après le tremblement
de terre des secours français vont
partir cette nuit Michel gorbachov sur
les lieux demain le premier voyage en
Occident d'un prix Nobel de la paix
valesa à Paris demain pour fêter les
droits de l'homme il est l'invité de ce
journal l'éducation nationale nouveau
chantier pour le Premier ministre Michel
Rocard dans le Limousin précise les
projets de rénovation du système
scolaire dérapage et vedetaria Sacha
Distel plaide non coupable à ne pour
l'accident qui a gravement blessé
Chantal Nobel en
85 madame monsieur bonsoir combien
sont-ils ensevelis sous les décom ombre
respirant peut-être encore dans ces
petites villes du nord de l'Arménie
soviétique ravagé hier par un terrible
tremblement de terre l'ampleur de la
catastrophe est telle qu'il est
impossible pour le moment d'évaluer le
nombre de morts mais ils se compteront
sans doute par dizaines de milliers
Patricia
cost impossible pour les habitants de
décrire le choc sous lequel ils sont
encore un jour et demi après le séisme
impossible encore maintenant de décrire
et de mesurer l'étendue du désastre
imaginez deux villes de plus de 200000
habitants ravagées les ninakan la deuxè
ville du pays détruite au 2 tiers tous
les immeubles de plus de 9 étages
effondrés kirovacan détruitite pour la
moitié et puis aussi spitac 50000
habitants Totalement rayés de la carte
et de nombreux villages autour de spitac
anéantis l'armée déjà présente sur les
lieux où elle imposait le couvre-feu
après les récents heures ethniques a pu
rapidement intervenir mais les BES
besoins sont immenses des équipes
médicales et des hôpitaux de campagne
ont été appelés de toute l'Union
soviétique vers l'Arménie des collectes
de sang sont organisé à Moscou en
Ukraine et même en Azerbaïdjan la
République voisine hier en guerre contre
l'Arménie un effort de solidarité qui a
permis au Premier ministre monsieur
richkov qui s'est rendu immédiatement
sur place d'insister sur la nécessaire
cohésion de toutes les républiques pour
venir en Inde à l'Arménie seule phrase à
connotation politique qui prend tout son
sens si souvient que c'est dans cette
région qu'avaent afflué les réfugiés des
poogrommes de l'Azerbaïdjan ils sont
aujourd'hui côte à côte avec les
sinistrés dans l'immense flot des
sansabris qui a dans le froid des hauts
plateaux caucasiens à la recherche d'un
git et heureusement la centrale
nucléaire près des rvane la capitale n'a
pas été touchée mais le tremblement de
terre a aussi ébranlé les républiques
voisines d'azerbaïjan et de geéorgie là
les dégâts ne sont que
matériels il pensent que des gens
souffrent et qu'il doit être là pour
diriger les for c'est en ces termes que
la nuit dernière à New York le ministre
soviétique des Affaires étrangères
annonçait le départ de Michael
gorbachchov et son retour à Moscou il y
est attendu ce soir il est dans l'avion
en ce moment Michael gorbachchov sera
demain en Arménie le président
soviétique qui a donc annulé son voyage
à Cuba et à Londres n'aura passé que 2
jours bien remplis à New York Paul
naon monsieur Gorbatchev a quitté la
mission soviétique située sur la 67e rue
et la 3
après avoir prévenu ronaldan FID Castro
et margar tcher en raison du tremblement
de terre en Arménie le secrétaire
général préfér regagn le plus vite
possible son
pays dans la nuit le ministre soviétique
des Affaires étrangères monsieurn don
des détails sur la catastrophe des
milliers de morts des gens souffr a-t-il
dit Monsieur Gorbatchev veut être à leur
côté à l'aéroport le numéro 1 soviétique
a remercié le peuple américain et New
York de son accueil cependant la
tragédie qui frappe mon pays m'oblige à
repartir ce brusque retour du secrétaire
général quelle que soit l'ampleur de la
catastrophe soulève des interrogations
en effet hier soir à New York à une
demi-heure d'interval deux officiels
soviétiques monsieur abrassimov et
chervernadz ont affirmé le premier que
Monsieur Gorbatchev ne renoncerait pas à
son programme malgré le tremblement de
terre en Arménie tandis que le second
annoncé le retour précipité du numéro un
soviétique à Moscou pour raisons
humanitaires les messages de sympathie
afflu du monde entier de François
mitteran au pape Jean-Paul II une équipe
de pompiers britanniques devrait partir
ce soir pour l'Union soviétique et la
France de son côté vient de recevoir le
feu vert de Moscou près de 200
spécialistes de la sécurité civile sont
sur le pied de guerre pour aller
renforcer les équipes de sauvetage
soviétique Hervé bzini la France
trouvera les moyens nécessaires de
confirmer
sa solidarité agissante si l'on a besoin
mais qu'au moins les populations
frappées
et toute la grande nation en
deuillé sache que nous partageons son
émotion la réponse soviétique à l'offre
de la France vient donc tout juste
d'arriver c'est un feu vert ces unités
d'intervention de la sécurité civile
vont très probablement rejoindre
l'Arménie dès ce soir plus de 200 hommes
6 tonnes de matériel et surtout ces
chiens que l'on avait vu au travail à
Mexico grâce à eux plus de 10 jours
après la catastrophe plusieurs vies ont
été sauvées à Brignol à Noan le retrou
donc tout le monde espère prendre
l'avion au plus vite dans les
circonstances de l'après tremblement de
terre chaqueur
compte l'émotion est grande bien sûr
dans la communauté arménienne FR et la
solidarité sorganise comme agnè Poirier
et Michel Montp l'ont constaté à les
moulau et à
alforvilleovagad spit leninagan des noms
de villes qui reviennent ici dans la
communauté arménienne comme une litanie
comme un moyen de se rapprocher des
lieux de cette catastrophe qui semble ce
soir si lointaine si
inaccessible le drame ici c'est qu'on
sait rien le téléphone est mué mais
qu'importe il faut organiser la
solidaritéé
a mis en place et l'église bien entendu
on ont mis en place donc une aide
humanitaire avec collecte de fonds pour
pouvoir acheter du matériel des
couvertures des des médicaments et
cetera enfin tout ce qu'il faut pour
aider les gens qui vont se retrouver à
la rue et et les blesser AER les blessés
essayer de déblayer et cetera en 2h 5000
francs ont déjà été collectés on vient
pour savoir pour donner on
s'inquiète j'ai eu les nouvelles ce
matin à la radio HPE qui est une radio
de la communauté européen arménienne en
France et je me sentais impuissante
devant les catastrophe qui s'est produit
en Arménie moi je suis d'origine de
l'Arménie soviétique et j'ai toute ma
famille mon père mes tantes mes sœurs
mes cousines qui se trouvent là-bas une
partie àinakan qui a été touché par les
catastrophe à kirovakan mon père il est
à Yerevan il paraît que même à Yerevan
il a eu plus de centaines de morts on on
sait pas le nombre de morts radio aïp
c'est la radio de la communauté
arménienne c'est ici que minute par
minute les dons affluent en plus grand
nombre chaque quart d'heure des flashes
d'information pour se donner peut-être
l'illusion d'être plus près là-bas nous
avons vu d'autres accidents de
l'histoire tous les envahisseurs sont
venus et sont partis et c'est comme le
rose l'Arménie et les Arméniens se sont
redressés comité SOS Arménie 15 rue Jean
goujan
75008 PARIS
oui plusieurs organisations humanitaires
sont prêtes à recueillir vos dons pour
les victimes à commencé par la Croix
Rouge voici le numéro de comptechèque
postal de la Croix-Rouge j'espère qu'il
va s'inscrire sur votre écran le voici
il faut donc bien spécifier mention
Arménie et puis l'ambassade soviétique
vient de me téléphoner à l'instant pour
exprimer la gratitude du gouvernement
aux personnes qui déjà ont apporté leur
don et l'ambassade communique aussi le
numéro de compte de la banque économique
extérieure du RSS une banque qui est
donc en France et qui peut recueillir
ses dons voici ce numéro de compte le
7004 12
70004 12 donc la banque économique
extérieure du
RSS en tout cas cet énorme tremblement
de terre dans des républiques déjà
déchirées par des conflits ethniques on
comprend que Michael gorbachchov est
interrompu une tournée internationale
pourtant prioritaire à ses yeux mais il
est vrai George bortolique encore une
fois le style et la et la politique
gorbachov n'ont rien à voir avec les
habitudes du kremelin oui ça n pas
habituel du tout effectivement et ça
montre plusieurs choses ça montre
d'abord que monsieur gbalchov a le sens
de l'improvisation puisque ce ce retour
a été visiblement improvisé à la
dernière minute comme le disait Paul n
tout à l'heure ça montre aussi que le
régime est maintenant personnalisé à
l'extrême il ne peut plus rien se passer
d'importance sans que Monsieur gorbachov
soit là sans que le qu'on le voit les
pieds dans la boue en train d'organiser
les secours et puis se rappelle qu'il y
a en Arménie un enjeu politique
important monsieur gorbachov va pouvoir
développer l'argument déjà esquissé par
le Premier ministre richkov tout à
l'heure à savoir que toute la grande
union soviétique est au chevet de
l'Arménie donc ce qui nous rassemble est
plus important que ce qui nous divise
alors il y a une autre question est-ce
que ce retour précipité serait en
rapport avec une fronde des généraux
après l'annonce de l'allègement des
effectifs ce qu'on ne sait pas c'est
pourquoi la démission du chef
d'état-major a été dramatisée à
l'extrême hier soir puisqu'elle a été
annoncée immédiatement après le discours
de Monsieur gorbachchov alors que dans
les habitudes militaires soviétiques on
pouvait très bien annoncer ça dans une
semaine ou deux ou trois il y a eu
dramatisation des libéré mais la
dramatisation ça fait aussi partie du
Ste
gorbachchov les décisions militaires
annoncées hier à l'ONU par Monsieur
gorbachov ont été accueillis en Occident
avec satisfaction mais aussi avec
prudence et tout à l'heure à la Chambre
des communes madame fatcher a bien
précisé qu'après les mesures de
désarmement unilatéral soviétique il y
aura toujours une asymétrie majeure
entre le Pacte de Varsovie et l'OTAN le
Conseil de l'Atlantique Nord précisément
s'est réuni uni comme prévu aujourd'hui
à Bruxelles les membres de l'OTAN à leur
tour proposent de limiter tous les
armements classiques en Europe bien en
dessous des niveaux actuels les
négociations est ouest doivent reprendre
sur ce sujet à Vienne en janvier
prochain mais c'est à bonne bien sûr que
les réactions au projet gorbachov sont
les plus positives surtout en ce qui
concerne le retrait de six divisions
blindées soviétiques de Hongrie
d'Allemagne de l'Est et de
Tchécoslovaquie Philippe Rochot
dans un pays où deux citoyens sur TR
font confiance à Gorbatchev les
réactions sont naturellement positive la
presse retient surtout que les
Soviétiques vont retirer six divisions
blindées d'Allemagne de l'Est et que le
danger d'une offensive du pacte de
Varsovie sur l'Europe se fera moins
sentir mais la réponse à donner ne doit
pas s'enliser dans le doute et le
scepticisme réaction très mesurée du
ministre allemand de la Défense Rupert
schz pour lui la réduction de 500000
hommes des troupes
bas en Europe de l'Est est d'abord le
résultat des efforts de l'Occident en
faveur de la détente mais il faut
attendre et voir si le retrait est
effectif et
vérifiable même position chez le
secrétaire de l'OTAN l'ancien ministre
allemand de la Défense monfred
wner la déclaration Gorbatchev va dans
la bonne direction mais il faut voir si
le retrait soviétique sera réellement
appliqué l'OTAN met au défi Gorbatchev
de retirer non pas 10000 mais 25000
blindé d'Europe de
l'Est la prudence de l'Allemagne et de
l'OTAN s'explique surtout par des
chiffres donnés par les experts
militaires allemands même en retirant
six divisions blindées d'Europe de l'Est
les forces du pacte de Varsovie
posséderont encore trois fois plus de
blinder que les forces de l'Alliance
atlantique Combre au tableau pour
Michael gorbachchov qui proposait hier
aussi un cesser le feu en Afghanistan
dès le 1er janvier prochain la
résistance afghane et le Pakistan ont
rejeté aujourd'hui cette proposition
irréaliste dis stle les mjahidines
Afghans veulent se battre jusqu'au
départ du dernier soldat soviétique
dit-on à
péchawir désarmement droits de l'homme
coopération économique ce sont les
thèmes de discussion que le président
mitteran a eu dès cet après-midi à
Prague avec son homologue tchck c'est la
première visite officielle d'un
président français en cchchoslovaquie
depuis la fondation du pays en 1918
Jean-Michel
Mercurol
l'annonce soviétique de réduction des
forces en Europe ne pouvait que ravir
François mitteran ici à Prague au moment
même où il entame une vaste tournée
diplomatique dans la plupart des pays de
l'Est le président de la République je
que c'est un vrai bon en avantsieur
kbatchov fait une proposition qui est
plus exactement une décision soviétique
et qui intervient avant même l'ouverture
de la négociation sur le désarmement
conventionnel qui va s'ouvrir
prochainement à Vienne et c'est une
décision qui est de bon augure pour ces
négociations que nous attendons de bon
augure aussi pour ce voyage entrepris en
tchéchoslovaquie un pays encore
réfractaire à la pérest Troïa où
François mitteran rencontrait
aujourd'hui Gustave housoussac et Milos
yakes c la même qu'il y a 20 ans ont
normalisé le pays après le Printemps de
Prague il a parlé avec eux
desésarmements conventionnel mais aussi
droits de l'homme demain matin il
recevra des opposants de chèqu et des
militants de la Charte des 77 est-ce un
simple effet de circonstance les
autorités de tèqu en tout cas ont pour
la première fois autorisé une
manifestation pour les droits de l'homme
à Prague le lendemain de la visite du
président français il sera à Paris
demain pour la première fois depuis 7
ans depuis l'instauration de l'état de
siège dans son pays l'ège valesa va
pouvoir quitter la Pologne pour venir en
Occident il sera il sera avec André
sakarov et Xavier Perez de cuellard le
secrétaire général des nations- Unies
l'invité d'honneur du président mitéran
aux célébration samedi du 40e
anniversaire de la Déclaration
universelle des droits de l'homme ce
soir lèche valesa vous l'avez vu est
àdansque avec Jacques merlinau dans le
presbyère de sainte-bgitte sa paroisse
bonsoir lesevala on vous connaît bien en
France on vous admire et disons-le on
vous aime vous avez 45 ans 8 enfants
vous êtes électricien prix Nobel de la
paix vous êtes le symbole d'une lutte
qui continue dans votre pays vous partez
demain pour Paris à quoi penserez-vous
dans
l'avion trudno poed
d Mad ài jeain
mais
j'espère il y aura
laibilité de penser à des choses
intéressantes mais je vais plutôt
essayer de ne pas penser à des questions
politique parce que j'aurais vraiment
besoin de mon cerveau à 100% de l'ordin
à 100 % le lendemain pour parler de ces
ch de ces chosesl qu'il faut résoudre
les JO les la semaine dernière les
autorités polonaises organisaient un
débat en direct à la télévision entre
vous et le président des syndicats
officiels aujourd'hui on vous laisse
sortir du pays comment expliquez-vous ce
nouveau comportement du
régime bien
s je jusqu'à ce jour je ne sais pas
comment qualifier cela mais on peut dire
que c'est quelque chose de
nouveau cette
rencontre à la télévision c'est
peut-être très original c'est peut-être
la première fois en 40 ans et ça c'est
une bonne chose donc il y a une petite
lueur
d'espoir espérons qu'il y aura quelque
chose derrière les il y a quelques jours
le gouvernement polonais a dit qu'il
allait reconsidérer son attitude envers
les membres de solidarité qui allait
abandonner la confrontation pour souvrir
à l'entente nationale alors est-ce votre
cas et peut-on dire aujourd'hui que le l
de 1988 est le même que celui de
1981 je pense que pour ce qui est des
choses essentielles c'est plus ou moins
la même chose mais cette an d'expérience
cette an de leçon a certainement eu un
effet un impact sur moi et sur les
autres personnes qui étaient au centre
de l'attention à cette ép là mais je
pense qu'en Pologne maintenant nous
pouvons commencer à penser à à une voix
commune comment pouvons-nous nous
libérer de du stalinisme qui pèse
toujours sur nous les est-ce que vous
pensez que la politique menée en Union
soviétique par Michel gorbachov est une
bonne chose pour les Soviétiques et pour
les pays de l'Est qui entourent Moscou
il est difficile pour moi de dire quoi
que ce soit au sujet d'une
superpuissance comme l'Union soviétique
je n'ai jamais été en Union soviétique
je ne sais pas exactement ce qui se
passe là-bas mais d'après ce qu'on voit
dans les
médias oui il lutte aussi contre ces
restes du stalinisme mais je ne suis pas
un expert je ne peux pas discuter d'une
façon intelligente là-dessus parce que
je c'est pas beaucoup mais si j'ai la
possibilité de parler avecsieur sov
pendant mon séjour à Paris ça sera
justement l'occasion d'prendre quelque
chose alors justement c'est à Paris que
vous allez rencontrer un autre prix
Nobel de la Paix l'homme qui avec vous
symbolise la lutte pour les droits de
l'homme André sakarov qu'avezvous
l'intention de lui
dire bien s j' votre attention à ce que
nous avons déjà dit pendant cette
intervie en Pologne nous ressentons
toujours le stalinisme ce n'est plus le
même stalinisme ce n'est plus le Tiran
les meurtres et cetera il y a eu
beaucoup de
changements mais certains aspects du
stanilisme comme le monopole du parti
politique des syndicats des ouvriers de
l'économie et cetera tout cela continue
à exister la nomenclatura aussi et ça
c'est quelque chose qu'il faut changer
sur une be légale est-ce que monsieur
sakarov a aussi ce point de vue ça on
verra bien ce sera une question qu'on
pourra poser aussi à André sakarov
puisque lui arrivera demain matin à
Paris les Vala merci on vous attend bien
sûr à Paris avec émotion et enthousiasme
un autre symbole de la lutte pour les
droits de l'homme Nelson Mendela vit
désormais en résidence sur surveillé
dans une villa à 50 km du Cap la voici
une villa tout près d'une prison mais
avec une piscine comme l'avaient annoncé
les autorités sud-africaines le chef
historique de la lutte anti-aparide
après 3 mois d'hôpital et 26 ans de
prison n'y retournera donc pas
Monseigneur toutou et ses partisans
réclament maintenant sa libération
inconditionnelle venons-en à l'actualité
en France et d'abord à la situation bien
confuse dans les transports parisiens
les usagers il faut le dire n'ont guerre
bénéficié aujourd'hui de l'amélioration
espérée après la signature hierre de
l'accord d'irection syndicat Françoise
Ji
surpris
perplexe pas d'autre solution il faut
faire demi-tour aujourd'hui une deuxième
ligne de métro était fermé pour les
Parisiens 24 heures après la signature
de l'accord à la RATP les usagers n'ont
pas vraiment pu apprécier la différence
avec des ores de pointe toujours
difficiles comme ici à la station étoile
sur certaines lignes seulement une rame
sur deux circulé des perturbations donc
qui persistent la RATP manque de
matériel en bon état de marche mais à
cela s'ajoute toujours la Grunne des
ouvriers d'entretien de certains dépôts
les grevvistes étaient encore
majoritaires ce matin dans plusieurs
ateliers notamment ce de Charonne
Fontenet ou encore saint-toin seule
véritable amélioration dans les bus
c'est sur les lignes A et B du RER où un
service réduit était assuré ce soir les
transports de remplacement comme les
camions militaires sont maintenus
jusqu'à ce weekend enfin la CGT elle ne
désarme pas demain elle appelle à une
manifestation devant le siège de la
RATP difficulté aussi pour ceux qui
devaient prendre l'avion aujourd'hui à
Orli il y avait une manifestation des
mécaniciens en grève à roissi l'accès à
l'aéroport comme à Nice était entravé
par une nouvelle l'opération escargot
des pharmaciens et puis attention à de
possibles coupures d'électricité demain
entre 9h et MH la CGT a en effet lancé
un appel à une journée nationale
d'action à
l'EDF la nation et son école c'est sur
ce thème que le premier ministre a
planché tout au long de la journée dans
le Limousin accompagné du ministre de
l'Éducation Lyonel JOSM il a visité
différents établissements et il a
précisé ses ambitions pour une école
moderne
bonjour comment ça va les jeunes
réaffirmer que l'éducation est la
priorité des priorités tel était
aujourd'hui l'objectif de Michel Rocard
un voyage à la rencontre de la réalité
quotidienne de la maternelle à
l'université de dialogue en discours le
Premier ministre a tracé les grandes
lignes de son projet éducatif sans nier
les difficultés je demande ici que l'on
me fasse
confiance la situation est à certains
égards plus grave je le pensais on ne
peut pas sortir de cette situation par
un coup de baguette magique il faut
fixer une orientation et des
échéances plusieurs années sont
nécessaires les engagements ont été pris
par le Président de la République est
tenu dans le cadre du budget
1989 ils seront également tenus dans le
cadre des qure budgets suivants 1990 91
92 93 chaque année l'État devra
accroître d'au moins 4 milliards au-delà
de son évolution normale le budget de
l'Éducation nationale pour réussir la
croissance la rénovation et la
revalorisation de l'enseignement parmi
les premières mesures annoncées 35
élèves maximum par classe dici à 5 ans
rééquilibrage de l'année scolaire les
cours se poursuivront jusqu'à fin juin
examen début juillet comment modifier en
douceur l'actionnariat stratégique des
entreprises privatisé entre 86 et 88
autrement dit les fameux noyaux durs
pierre bergovois le ministre de
l'économie et des finances a annoncé
aujourd'hui un projet de loi pour le
printemps et dans ce sens Claire Chazal
en constituant des noyaux durs
c'est-à-dire des blocs d'actionnaires
stables dans les entreprises privatisées
Édouard Baladur souhaitait
officiellement protéger ces sociétés
mises sur le marché par exemple Paribas
contre d'éventuelles raides extérieurs
les membres de ces noyaux durs
c'est-à-dire des banques des assurances
parfois publiques comme l'UAP avait deux
obligation légale conservver leur part
pendant 2 ans et les tro années
suivantes ne les céd qu'après l'avis du
conseil d'administration pierre
berégovois veut aujourd'hui par la loi
rendre leur liberté à ses actionnaires
particuliers tous les candidats à
l'exception de Monsieur Jacques Chirac à
l'élection présidentielle tous les
candidats ont condamné la méthode qui
avait été choisie par le gouvernement
précédent ainsi chacun retrouvera sa
liberté je crois que c'est une très
bonne chose et un bon signe que nous
donnons à ceux qui nous observent sur le
plan international après l'offensive
lancée contre la Société Générale
considérée par l'opposition comme une
tentative de renationalisation la loi
bergovois permet surtout de clarifier
les intentions du Gouvernement et le
débat
politique l'ancien ministre de
l'Industrie Alain Madelin a déclaré tout
à l'heure à RTL qu'il n'était pas
hostile au principe d'une telle liberté
de manœuvre Alain Jupé lui prend la
défense des petits porteurs d'action des
mêmes privatisés pour le secrétaire
général du RPR il existe des solutions
pour exonérer des frais de garde pour
les exonérés des frais de gardes que
veulent désormais leur imposer les banqu
par ailleurs Alain Jupé considère que
Raymond bar s'est rallié d'une certaine
manière à la majorité à partir du moment
où l'ancien Premier ministre a annoncé
son intention de ne pas voter demain
soir la motion de censure déposée par le
RPR Bernard tapis repart à l'attaque à
Marseille il a annoncé aujourd'hui son
intention de se représenter en mars
prochain dans cette 6e circonsrp
où l'élection de son rival UDF avait été
annulé par le Conseil
constitutionnel encore un accident
d'avion en Allemagne fédérale un avion
militaire américain s'est écrasé en
plein centre de la ville de remshade
bilan 5 morts et des dégâts
considérables après les explosions et
les incendies qui vous le voyez ont donc
ravagé le centre de cette ville de
l'ouest du
pays
manifestation
proalestinienne aujourd'hui à Paris pour
marquer le premier anniversaire du
soulèvement dans les territoires occupés
par Israël une marche
silencieuse que vous voyez ici une
marche au flambeau à l'appel de diverses
organisations
proestiniennes en 6 Jordanie un
Palestinien été tué qu autres blessé
aujourd'hui et la grève générale a été
largement suivie
charleserlin Hébron ce matin comme dans
toute la sjordanie et Gaza la grève est
totale plus que jamais après la
proclamation d'Alger et les déclarations
d'Arafat à Stockholm les populations
palestiniennes observent les appels du
comité clandestin du
soulèvement les renforts très importants
acheminés par l'armée israélienne n'ont
pas eu à intervenir il n a eu qu'un seul
incident grave plus au nord dans un
village près de Jine un mort et blessés
en un an dans les territoires il y a eu
245 mors palestinen selon les militaires
plus de 400 selon des sources
palestiniennes 8 israéliens ont été tués
et 1100 blessés le nombre de blessés
Palestiniens dépasse les
4000 la presse de Jérusalem est sous
très haute surveillance n'a pu que faire
allusion à cet anniversaire du
soulèvement elle a consacré ses
premières pages aux prises de position
du chef de l'OLP en Suède pour conclure
que la balle est désormais dans le camp
israélien le soulèvement se poursuivra
jusqu'à la fin de l'occupation
israélienne a déclaré aujourd'hui à
Tunis Yasser Arafat Yasser Arafat dont
les propos d'hier à Stockholm sont
commenté avec la plus grande
circonspection en
Israël une courte peine de prison avec
surcis une amende et le retrait du
permis pendant quelques mois telle est
la sanction qu'au tribunal correctionnel
de ne à l'instant le procureur vient de
demandé contre Sacha Distel Chantal
Nobel grièvement blessé dans sa voiture
en 85 avait porté plainte Pascal
Deschamp décidément ce ne pouvait être
le procès ordinaire d'un banal accident
de la route en témoignait d'abord la
foule venue trop nombreuse pour la
petite salle du tribunal de neverre venu
pour voir deux stars à la barre en
témoignait surtout l'arrivée mouvementé
de l'inculpé dans la mêlée le public
soupirait d'aise il n'était pas tout à
fait venu pour rien Chantal Nobel elle
avait préféré se faire représenté par
son mari l'actrice souffre encore de
trop de séquel de son terrible accident
l'audience avait pour but d'en éclaircir
les circonstances pourquoi la Porsche
937 de Sacha Distel avait-elle quitté la
route le 28 avril 85 les experts ont
écarté l'excès de vitesse privilégiant
l'état glissant de la chaussée mais le
procureur de la République lui a trouvé
leur conclusion trop favorable à
l'accusé un procureur qui avait prévenu
mes réquisitions seront celles que
j'aurais faite pour n'importe quel
monsieur Dupont ni Vernet pour lui en
tout cas aujourd'hui sachadadel était un
inculpé comme les autres
une image émouvante pour terminer ce
journal bien chargé l'actualité était
pesante aujourd'hui voici c'est tout
simplement la plus vieille dame du monde
ces statuettes ont été découvertes par
des archéologues en Autriche et elle
date d'environ 30000 ans 30000 ans
peut-être plus
encore et puis très vite les rapports
les résultats et les rapports du quarté
de Vincen que vous allez décou ouvrir le
tierscé plutôt sur votre écan donc à
l'arrivée le 9 le 6 et le 4 5 francs
dans l'ordre 247 francs 50 dans un ordre
différent 49 franc 50 voilà Laurent
Cabrol va bien sûr vous parler du temps
de demain dans un instant euh tout à
l'heure notre dernière édition vous sera
présentée par Henry sagier demain 6h45
Roger Zabelle à demain 20h très bonne
soirée
[Musique]